all right let's see if it's working all
right what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel
all right um I need to get a one in the
chat to make sure that the stream is
working because we are um I am in
Chicago right now I'm at my parents
house so um get a one in the chat if you
can hear me one in the chat if
everything's working um today um we are
going to be reacting to Andrew Tate's
first interview
um after being on house arrest as you
guys know
um the fake news CNN media
reaction channels CNN of YouTube has
been slandering Andrew for months months
this man
they have been looking for a reason to
arrest him for no reason an innocent man
okay let me let me backtrack for those
of you that don't know
um I was one of the last people to
interview Andrew before he got arrested
so back in um December Andrew um came on
one of my panels on the show and a
couple weeks later
um I got word that he had been arrested
for I think it was human trafficking and
basically the city or the country of
Romania has been digging trying to find
any dirt on this man for months
months okay
and they have found nothing zero NADA
they've pressed zero charges but they've
been able to put this guy in prison
um they have been able to now have him
on a house arrest they just extended it
another 30 days
with zero evidence and zero charges
now it's crazy because this if this is
was able to happen to a man with money
power status and influence what does
that mean for the average guy
what does that mean for the average Joe
um so today I am going to be reacting to
his first interview after you know
being arrested minus you know the one
that he sort of offered you know
um
let's see let's
sogoy's Andrews just released a new
interview with the BBC if you want to
join the real world we have a link in
the description
you've agreed to do an interview with
the BBC today yeah the material is going
to be published oh and I need to I need
to add this is the unedited version so
BBC had a fake news
a fake news story where they edited out
all of you know the juicy Parts but
we're not going to react to that because
we don't need any fake news reaction
Channel
CNN drama channels we we report the real
footage here the real footage okay
television or radio online perfect
we are doing an interview with you
because you're facing some very serious
allegations correct rape human
trafficking and also because there's a
great deal of concern about the things
you say and the impact that they have on
young people on women I don't think the
concerns about the things I say I think
the concern is for the level of
influence they have and the reach I have
I would argue that a lot of things that
are already out there inside of the
Legacy Media The Matrix Soul are far
more damaging than the things I say
concern about the influence you have
being a harmful influence but let's
start with the allegations not
necessarily a harmful influence the fact
that I have I'm massively influential
over the youth and I understand that but
it's my influence as a whole which
people are afraid of not necessarily the
things let's start with the allegations
have you raped anybody absolutely not
have you trafficked anybody absolutely
not exploited any women absolutely not
but you have admitted using emotional
manipulation to get women to work in the
webcam industry for you no
I wish to God I wish to God okay I went
home to my dad and I said hey Dad
I've been gone a couple months okay
and this guy this like super rich dude
in Romania brought me into his mansion
took me luxury shopping
I got to ride in his Bugatti but yeah I
was I was human trafficked I wish I
would
you know my dad would say to me do you
know what my dad would say to me
he would look at me and say you're an
idiot my dad's blunt like that it's like
what
I just want to know what these women's
fathers said to them I don't know
firstly let's begin let's start in the
beginning I'm facing charges the one the
first one you mentioned the rape one's
already started out by a judge because
there's no episode
secondly it's very difficult for me to
sit here and have a very Frank and
honest conversation with you while we're
in the territory of Romania about
illegal cases going on within Romania I
have to protect myself I've agreed to do
an interview with you I don't want to be
as honest with you as possible but I
can't incriminate myself in any way and
I have to be very careful with what I
talk about there are no charges yet
correct there are no charges there are
no charges and I've agreed to speak to
you
and I thought we were innocent until
proven guilty
but I thought
I thought the headspace these
interviewers CNN drama channels fake
news media goes into things they go in
with a narrative
and that's why I got so much criticism
for interviewing Nick right I got so
much criticism for not pushing back for
going in with an open mind but this is
like the level of Journalism that we
have nowadays it's not people looking
for the truth it's people that are
looking to spin a narrative and they're
not like does this look like an
open-minded woman looking for the facts
she married let me know in the chat is
she married
but I have to be as honest and Frank as
I can while also protecting myself and
following my legal counsel so let's talk
about what you've said yourself then you
have said
the Hustler's University that you
emotionally manipulated women to fall in
love with you so that you could get them
working in the sex industry for your
financial gain as I said I have to be
very careful with what I say but let's
put it this way no women are coming out
against me and accusing me of doing it
yes they are no they're not yes they are
no they're not who there's testimony
from the current investigation the
current investigation which I cannot
discuss which I know intimately and you
don't I can tell you right now that the
late the women who are in this case File
there are two American women who have
been caught already admitting their
lying and then nobody else is accusing
me of anything to begin with it's very
common in cases like this that the
alleged victims do not always see
themselves as victims well that's very
interesting it's actually extremely
interesting because if I was
a matrix controlled
so let me get this straight
I can go into something and say I'm not
a victim and he's going to something and
say oh she's not a victim
and now the outside can tell me that I'm
a victim
why are we why do we want women to be
victims so bad
so but look at what if you don't even
know if those women what if they pursued
him
I'm sure if he had an application
work as a webcam chick
live in my mansion
driving my Bugatti all this stuff you
know women would be lining up to do it
let's not pretend let's not pretend okay
I just
organization my goal was to slander
somebody and try and destroy their name
you're telling me that they've chosen a
crime which one is heinous of course
because it damages the person's
credibility and two you're saying that
even if everyone else involved if you
have five people and everyone's sitting
there saying no nobody's hurt anybody we
like Andrew we've all we're together
we're friends Etc not what everybody
says no let me read you some of the
testimony from the current investigation
can I finish one of the witnesses said
can I finish this
you're not answering the question I am
answering the question you're saying
you're saying the people who are
involved in this even if they say
they're not victims that they're still
going to try and attack me and pretend
they're victim treated as victims by the
case that's ongoing and not all of them
are saying that one of the witnesses
says
we can't just we can't go into the case
the case is open and active
well let's just be clear that not all of
the witnesses
Andrew I wouldn't do you like that I'm
just saying I'm just saying come back to
jpt okay
well we'll come to you you know what I
mean I'm just saying we if you asked us
not to ask you about certain things we
don't do what the fake news media does
the drama channels do the gotcha moments
we go into interviews in good faith
are behaving in the way you describe and
even those that are it doesn't bother
them from being treated as victims by
the prosecution by the case we have an
open criminal investigation I am
absolutely not really sure how we found
innocent I know the case better than you
I know it intimately and you don't I
have seen all the criminal files and the
evidence against me and you haven't I
know the truth of what happens and you
don't and I'm telling you absolutely not
really I've never hurt anybody that the
case that's been put against me is
completely not only fabricated and I've
never really found guilty of anything
and it's very difficult for me to answer
your in-depth questions because we're
sitting here inside of the territory of
Romania I'm beholden to the Romanian
legal system and I'm not going to
incriminate myself because you're trying
to prog me you are wrong and we're gonna
have to accept that for now and ask and
talk about something else let me read
you then what you have said about what
you have done sure you have said my job
was to meet a girl go on a few dates
sleep with her get her to fall in love
with me to the point where she'd do
anything I say and then get her on
webcam so we could become Rich together
I don't think that's what I personally
said I think that's exactly no that's
that's that's no I've never said that
that's something that you found on the
internet doesn't mean I've said it and
and again once again if any female on
the planet has a problem with me I
strongly recommend her to go to the
police and try and pursue me for
criminal charges
all right let's just take that okay
let's just take that let's just say he
said that okay let's let's take that on
its core
oh he's saying he didn't say that I
don't know right let's just say he said
it okay
if you go on a date with a guy sleep
with him
fall in love with him and then do only
fans
like ladies take your L what happened
what happened to taking L's in silence
sometimes in life you just take it out
you know maybe the girl goes in a couple
dates sleeps with them now he's trying
to be have her as a part of his cam
business which some girls would take as
a w right some girls you get to live in
the Bugatti the Mansion all that stuff
so some some girls this is a W for
but I mean
for me that would be a bit of an L you
know what I mean but sometimes you just
gotta take your L's in peace
it's not human trafficking
it's not
you got it's just you know else
else okay so
actually very interesting that me one of
the most famous people in the world
who's been vilified by the Legacy Media
and places all over the Internet while
everyone has attacked me from every
single angle while federal agencies from
multiple countries have called over 2
000 women who know me we stand here with
zero new accusations since my arrest
zero if you took any famous person any
man of substantial wealth and you called
2 000 women who knew him you'd find an
ex-girlfriend is upset somebody wants
money who's upset they call 2 000 people
who knew me and could not find a single
woman to make a new complaint the only
the only complaints they have against me
are the initial complaints which we can
prove our lives and
that's where it stands so I I'm not
going to sit here and allow you to
pretend that I'm some kind of evil
Predator when actually I'd argue the
fact I'd argue the fact that people
who've been investigating to the level
I've been investigated to if you were to
the average man on the street and
investigate his entire life for 14
months call everyone who's ever known
him and vilify him in the media and
encourage people to come forward for
money and you try to contact every ex
girlfriend that's ever happened would
come forward and accuse those people um
of rape and accusation I think that you
would have a lot more I think you would
have a lot more Flack than I've got I'm
actually such a nice person
to somebody sits your arrest who says
exactly those things that with you it's
all manipulation there's an ulterior is
this Sophie
oh Sophie the the fake name no face no
one's got the story that was invented to
please him and wanting him to be happy
you should have a right to face your
accuser if you're gonna accuse someone
of something
it's my opinion that I was just kind of
yeah okay do whatever you want and what
if she if she accused me of a crime this
imaginary Sophie she's making the point
that there is has she accused me of a
crime emotional or psychological
manipulation okay this I have a rant I
have a rant this is the problem all
right we keep calling everything abuse
everything like coercive control
emotional manipulation we have lost the
real meaning
of human trafficking the real meaning of
abuse the real meaning of manipulation
and where's the accountability okay if
those women worked the webcams those
women were trying to do the same thing
those women were getting men to fall in
love with them
okay they're they were getting men to
fall in love with them and extracting
resources from the men so are the women
equally as accountable for the
manipulation that they were doing guys
sometimes in life you take L's it's not
a crime
sometimes I like and this is the thing
is women we get so bitter
it's just it's an L it's an l
good question and I've allowed you into
my house I'm asking you a question
correct but you're not the boss here
because I've allowed you into my house
I'm asking you the question correctly
and I'm telling you you get to decide
the answer no we're equal here I've
allowed you into my house you don't come
here with a position of authority I'm
doing you the favor it's the Legacy
Media giving you relevance by speaking
to you and I'm telling you now this
if you
want to give anyone relevance
by speaking you can ask me whatever
questions you can you can all right
which is no Face-Off nobody knows who
she is of course not and she because you
never invent anything and she's not
[__] she's not filed criminal charges
against me what are we talking about
here what is she saying about emotional
manipulation she's the sex industry for
your financial day absolute garbage she
has not found this person if they exist
has not found criminal charges against
me I welcome anybody who believes I've
harmed them male or female any point in
the past the file criminal charges
against me I'll fight them I know who I
am I know what I've done and I know the
truth and I know that I'll be found
innocent of this attack the reason I'm
being attacked is because of my massive
influence not because I've ever hurt
anybody and for you to sit here and say
that everybody around you is saying
you're Innocent but that doesn't matter
because the state will say they're
victims and they're just gonna
grab everybody you know and call
everybody victims even if they say
they're not and try and put you in jail
you are describing a matrix attack
you're not describing human trafficking
I'm describing women who are going to
court to accuse you of rape and human
trafficking we will see what women do we
will see what women go to court can I
finish trials we'll see which women go
we'll see which one we live for I'm
describing women who are going to court
to accuse you of rape making music
I'm describing women who have spoken to
the BBC at length Sophie doesn't exist
and other media organizations about what
they say is emotional manipulation
coercion and I'm quoting back to you
your own words where you describe
they're
words you found on the internet and
Sophie doesn't exist so let's move on to
the next subject move on to the next
subject no I think I'll stick on this
one for a minute so there's other
other this woman the audacity this woman
has the audacity it's like
dude invited you
everyone everyone wants this interview
everybody he gave it to you
and you can't even follow the rules of
engagement whatever
you say you get girls to fall in love
with you and they do it because they
love you because they want to do what
you say
convincing women to take part in some
kind of business okay so my dad asked me
to Garden today
I love my dad
I did some watering you know what I mean
I'm a big waterer
um was I emotionally manipulated because
I love my dad
do you see the sunburn
I was abused one could say
the abuse the abuse
so tired of women crying abuse gosh darn
everything this Arrangement doesn't work
long term because they're emotional
you've got to get people in love with
you
that's emotional manipulation that's
abuse what you've found are clips from
the internet some text from the internet
and you're gonna sit here and tell me
that that's the reason I should be your
website your words it's on my website
yes it is no it's all check my website
next
it's the website you've taken down and I
wonder why those comments have been
taken no websites no websites are taken
down my website is the same it's been
the same for a very long time the
comments on this website on the original
website have been taken down and I
wonder why you are accusing me I'm
guessing what you're trying to say is
you're accusing me and you're trying to
say that I'm guilty of the things I'm
accused of and I'm emotionally
manipulating people I'm saying that you
have set your emotionally manipulated
people here for your own Financial
getting no absolutely not and I'm asking
you about that absolutely not is the
answer I look forward to the end of this
trial I look forward to clearing my name
I look forward to the BBC and the Legacy
Media having to say not guilty and
having to tell the truth as I've said
before the only other person who's been
found despite absolute rigorous
destructive levels of investigation and
prodding into my life is this imaginary
Sophie by the BBC who doesn't exist and
if you were to find any single other man
on Earth and try and analyze his life
forensically to the level they've done
mine you would find genuine damage to
people I don't hurt people
it's not just thousands of women have
come out of my defense
thousands of women have come out my
defense and you've not mentioned that
thousands of women come out of my
defense because the the problem is when
women accuse you of serious crimes okay
let's agree that thousands of women
let's agree the problem that some people
say you haven't done it it's a problem
that someone
thousands of women come out my defense
and as we stand right now we have open
criminal investigation the people who
are involved in the criminal
investigation are saying that we're not
you don't think that if someone was a
human trafficker they'd have like a
baby I'm crazy victims of anything
Andrew's fine he's never hurt us you're
saying no I have the opposite to that I
have to counter that I have someone
called Sophie with no face a fake name
who we've invented and she's not
accusing you of anything criminal so I
don't see the whole point you're trying
to manipulate women they say you
manipulate women why wouldn't people
think you do I'm not here do you think
I'm manipulating you
I'm asking you about the testimony
you've given on your website and the
testimony you've printed something off
that you found on Reddit and you're
going to sit here and say that that
makes me a bad person I'm saying that
you should know better as a journalist
and do some proper journalism let's
investigate the fact that thousands you
should answer my questions
I already have and we should move on
she's just trying to start home it's not
only about the criminal allegations it's
a much bigger issue you've got
children's organizations in the UK
you've got rape organizations in the UK
you've got the police naming You by name
as someone who has a harmful influence
on children and on women in the UK and
elsewhere because of the things you say
because of the way you present
gender relations the way you say men
should treat women that's very upsetting
and the reason that's very upsetting is
because I know that's not true I'm
genuinely a good person I believe my
impact on the world is positive in fact
if you were to read the comments section
of nearly any video I post especially by
the Legacy Media 95 of the population
agree with me most people know the
things I say are positive Legacy Media
as a whole has lost all its credibility
in the last three to four years nobody
believes it and it's a shame it's a
massive shame that the BBC come here and
try and push and purport this idea that
I'm a dangerous person
I'm I'm anti-drug so I've never pushed
drugs or any uh I'm anti-drugs romantic
violence we're the UK is facing a nice
crime epidemic and they're going to see
what I'm saying they're going to sit
here and say that I'm the most dangerous
man in the UK only you're the most
dangerous man in the world I've said I'm
the most dangerous man in the world
you also said that
oh man the world and you believe that's
when did I say that I'm asking if you
believe it no you said you said you said
you're the most dangerous man in the
world is that some kind of proof that
I'm dangerous am I Dr Evil now I'm
telling you that it's very upset that
you're gonna sit here and that certain
organizations in the world are going to
try and pretend that I'm the biggest
force of evil on earth when I'm
genuinely a Force for good I'm genuinely
a force for God and the and the reason
they're doing this is because of the
massive influence I have over the youth
and they don't like that I'm telling the
youth to think outside in The Matrix and
ignore things like the BBC which come
here with loaded questions and false
narratives and try and paint innocent
people as as guilty you've said women's
intimate Parts belong to their male part
I said that if a woman marries a man she
takes his last name and traditionally
the man gives her away I've been pushing
to
religious beliefs because I'm a
religious man and traditional beliefs in
regards to marriage which everybody
accepted 10 to 15 years ago that's not
that's not that's not a crazy conspiracy
theory if you're gonna sit here and say
that me believing a woman should take a
Man's last name in marriage makes me the
most dangerous man in the world then
you're just gonna lose even more
credibility than the BBC's already lost
in the last four to five years if that's
your point if that's your narrative you
should be able to with a lot of women
outside marriage that doesn't sound very
religious that's not what I said they
should be able to I said a lot of high
value men a lot of rich men do it and
then we discussed at length on podcasts
why rich men do it and we also discussed
why women decide to be unfaithful it's
not a gendered argument we discuss
unfaithfulness as a whole what are the
reasons and motivations for men and what
are the reason motivations for women and
that is the most misconstrued point of
the freaking rad pill is that we push
cheating
I'm well to be fair Tate did have a
cheating party the first time I watched
Tate I was a little triggered I saw a
cheating party but but
it's like is this an interview in good
faith
is this an interview really digging for
the truth or is it
pushing a narrative are these leading
questions is she trying to get a
30-second gotcha moment and that's what
the reaction channels do that's what the
freaking CNN fake news media does
BBC it's like all of this stuff
uh I mean even when uh on my dog's in
here even when um Andrew Tate went on
BBC with Pierce Morgan what'd they do
they're trying to get him in a gotcha
question Pierce Morgan cut cut him off
like 20 times
um
yeah yeah okay
because you
oh and and I forgot this point I forgot
this point you're gonna tell me you're
gonna tell me
that you don't want to belong to your
husband it's like what
these Independent Women it's like why
get married if you want to be
independent
stay by yourself
stay stay in the relationship Lane just
don't don't get don't get married
because you have no time to actually
watch my content because you have no
time to actually watch my content like
and understand what I'm saying you just
come here with a small snippet which has
been provided doesn't make it true no
completely you don't have a clue what I
say or what I talk about you never watch
my content you have small pieces of
paper small Clips on a piece of paper
and you're trying to pretend I've said
evil things and then you're going to
send the most dangerous man in the world
which is truly lovely you said not me
okay do you believe in the most
dangerous man in the world Lucy I'm not
answering your questions well then we
well then we need to change the dynamic
of this interview because and I'll make
this clear I allowed you into my home
I'm doing you a favor give you the first
interview I'm giving to the public you
don't come here with a position of
authority you're not the police I don't
respect the BBC I don't know you you do
not come here with a position of
authority over me we are equals we are
people we're citizens of the world and
we sit here as equals and I see you as
my equal and if you ask me questions I
can ask you questions back for you to
come here and sit down and pretend
you're the gestapo and that you don't
have to answer my questions is is
disingenuous because I don't owe you any
asking questions and
this is a conversation and I don't owe
you any degree of authority over me so
let's make that clear and that doesn't
matter if you're a man or a woman or
from the BBC or the CNN I'm here to
answer your questions and be honest with
you and do you a favor but and I'm doing
you a favor but you come here with
loaded questions you're trying to paint
a narrative of me which is negative I'm
asking you and that's fine you've said
that people are concerned about it and
that's fine but you're not going to sit
here and say you don't answer my
questions because you're not above me
in 30 degrees
absolutely well it would help if you
answered the question I've answered
every question so far let me uh
did you hear the person she's like it's
supposed to be a conversation Lady this
is not a conversation
a conversation like we can ask each
other questions
and this is what the media does it's so
disingenuous and people are tired of it
and you guys even saw it on the freaking
um
fresh and fit stream yesterday you saw
how all the reaction channels take
things we say out of context and try to
paint a narrative it is so hard to find
people that do Fair journalism nowadays
that go into things without an agenda
with a genuine
curiosity about the world trying to
figure out what's true and not true like
most people have things that are good
about them and good things that are bad
about them they're not a hundred percent
either or but everyone is looking for
the one nail in the coffin to get tape
is Tate perfect no nobody's perfect like
you dig into anyone you're gonna find
some statements that maybe don't look
the best or you're gonna find like
you're gonna you're gonna find something
when you dig into anyone but for how
he's right for how much they dig into
him for how much they used to dig into
Kevin Samuels like what what have they
really found they found some bitter exes
I mean most men have bitter exes
uh you know and to say I wish I keep
saying this I wish I would go home
and tell my dad that I lived in a
mansion I was luxury shopping and I was
trafficked I I wish I wish I would ask
me another question sure you have said a
woman's intimate part I actually can I
should I call my dad I'm gonna see what
he says
um
let's see
let's see I want to see if he answers
I'm gonna see if he answers I want to
see what my dad says
can you guys hear it
okay wait maybe I should
we'll see if he answers I don't know if
he'll answer
oh I'm peeking
maybe I should try my brother my dad's
not answering
hey this is my father's phone
okay not should I try Adam are you guys
annoyed should I
I'm gonna try my other brother
hey question
I'm streaming just so you know
okay
um if I lived in a mansion
and I fell in love with a guy I lived in
a mansion and then I did Cam work for a
couple of months
um and then maybe he wrote what go ahead
not what you do now shut up stop it stop
trolling okay all right what
patient confuses me oh shut up okay if I
did if I did real cam work like taking
off clothes sex work okay you know I
don't stop stop doing that you know what
you're doing
um lit what
stop it okay b b okay be honest be
honest so I fall in love with the guy I
move into his big mansion He Paid he
takes me luxury shopping I live like a
queen okay in this Mansion but I'm doing
cam work
and I came back to you and I said Adam
Adam I've been trafficked human
trafficked
would you what would you say
I mean why did she go
you wouldn't you wouldn't say like oh
you feel really bad for me
I would want to know why she went that
would be the first what if what if I
said I went because I loved him was I
trafficked
oh she loves if she loves girls but only
do you can work and you're gonna put
yourself in that level if you're gonna
if you fall in love with the script this
guy and he only loves girls that are
[__] they're very clearly like women
that
part of my language Horrors that are
only women that like that have to go
down to that level then if that's what
he likes man you're doing it like your
joy is not his I mean you're doing it to
appease him you're right it's like like
anybody's trying to appease you is your
problem would you would you feel bad for
me living in the Mansion going luxury
shopping every day
see but like it's nothing to do with the
mainstream it's everything to do with
like whether the Mansion even matter in
the sun it's like the if you're doing
the camera for the guy or to be appealed
to this guy to be around this guy and
then therefore you're doing it by your
choice to appease this guy who probably
doesn't give a [__] about you let's be
realistic
thank you I just I just wanted to check
because apparently they're saying this
is human trafficking nowadays so just
wanted
to double check that that wouldn't be
human trafficking
I mean if you're trying to appease
anybody's will generally just being
Indus okay okay thank you I gotta I
gotta go back to the video the chat's
getting mad
thank you goodbye
that's why I'm gonna go out
there you have it guys
call me crazy I don't know belong to her
male partner and if she goes on only
fans he is entitled to a cut of her
income you are extremely it's actually
very it's very confusing to me why
you're gonna sit here take long format
podcasts I've done which are three or
four hours long in context where I sat
with only fans girls 10 or 15 only fans
girls where we've been joking back and
forth ignore every comment and satirical
comment and sarcastic comment that the
females have made and then come along
and say you said this and that you're
the most evil man in the world I don't
know if you understand what sarcasm is I
don't know if you understand what
sarcasm is I don't know if you
understand what context is I don't know
if you understand what's uh satorical
content so you're saying it's sarcastic
I'm saying it was a very interesting
talk show and for you to sit here and
say that that is my true core beliefs
and that makes me a bad person is
disingenuous of course not was it
sarcasm absolutely you should watch the
show you were being sarcastic when you
said let me clarify you should watch the
show let me clarify for the audience
were being sarcastic when you said a
woman's intimate Parts belonged to her
male partner no I didn't believe that no
it's not that it's that you haven't
watched the show at length and you
should have because the woman was saying
my man's car belongs to me because he's
my man and she was on only fans and then
20 minutes later when she said she was
on only fans and said ah well you're
selling your body that belongs to him
because he's your man and she laughed
she laughed she laughed and she said
haha yeah that's probably true if you
watch the show if you watch the show it
will make sense for you to come here
with doing no research at all and then
say I don't understand what I'm talking
about but I've got this piece of paper
with a few things printed off that's why
you're saying the silly things you're
saying you should watch the show do some
research do you believe it I've already
answered the question not really
do you believe that a woman's intimate
Parts belong to her mail of course not
I've just answered the question
yeah we've done that three times and and
does this woman believe that her man's
car belongs to her
we it's it's not a gendered argument I
really think that it's genuinely sad
that when the BBC has a chance to
finally interview me at the end of all
this Matrix attack that they don't come
here with any kind of genuine openness
to try and understand my influence of
the world or the things I push or what
I'm trying to teach the world or why I'm
a good influence on the world because I
am the massively good influence instead
they come here with pieces of paper with
printed out excerpts from five-year-old
podcasts taken out of context to
attempting the same to attempt the same
Matrix attack on me which has been
attempted endlessly to every single
person Legacy Media has already tried
this and it doesn't work you I really
encourage you I encourage you to read
the comment section on the on YouTube
when this goes on YouTube and you'll see
that nobody believes a word you're
saying the Reason God I'm asking you
about these comments is because we've
got the chief executive of Rape Crisis
naming you individually
no
not the chief executive of of great
crisis no
not like
they call and look it look it
they call everything grape these days
they call everything a salt they have
expanded the definition that they have
lost its meaning and I guarantee
guarantee the chief executive of grape
crisis is some male feminists or female
feminist that just wants to paint him as
a bad guy without knowing any of the
facts of the case guarantee
guarantee
are spreading a dangerous ideology of
misogynistic rape culture absolutely
it's the comments you make that are
leading people to say things like
absolute National organizations who are
saying that are blaming you no
not the national organizations
not the
not the not the national organizations
that that is too far
Tate must be a bad guy that is too far
the national organizations have come
gosh increasing levels of misogyny
schools that are saying they are having
increased incidents of girls being
attacked the female teachers being
harrised if that was something
that's absolutely that's absolute
garbage I have never ever encouraged a
student to attack a teacher male or
female ever I preach hard work
discipline I'm an athlete I preach
anti-drug I preach religion I preach no
alcohol I preach uh no knife crime every
single problem with modern society I'm
against I'm teaching young men I'm
teaching young men to be disciplined to
be diligent to listen to train to work
hard to be exactly like me with no
criminal record never even yet charged
in this 14-month Matrix investigation
and I'm saying that men grow up like me
which are hard-working and diligent as
emotional control and stoic we're gonna
have a better Society not a worse
Society to sit here and say that schools
in England England which is a failing
nation which has life crime going
through the roof violence going through
the roof men's mental health going
through the roof and they're gonna all
blame me because I appeared on the
internet one year ago disingenuous it's
disingenuous and also also financial
success
cigar but it comes with a side order of
misogyny how does having a Bugatti and a
cigar come with a misogyny because it's
all mixed together in what you teach you
teach that a woman if a woman comes home
and accuses you of cheating you should
hit her with a machete shove her up is
that is that what I teach that's what
you say no if you actually watch the
kids it will be about the woman
attacking me with a machete as usual
you've not watched the video taken out
of context flipped it and attempted it
to attack me with a small exha let me
tell you something Lucy I'm sure you're
a very nice person I'm sure you're a
fantastic person but if I were to take
everything you've ever said online and
just take small excerpts out of context
I could make you look like a misogynist
I guarantee it in fact I might actually
do that and then you're going to sit
here and say oh [__] I'm a misogynist
because my Clips have been taken out of
context if you refuse to wash anything
at length and understand it then that's
what's going to happen the National
Police Chiefs leave for violence against
women the nspcc Rape Crisis safe for
schools they are all naming you
as being behind an epidemic of misogyny
even amongst
not an epidemic of misogyny no
why God why
I am so tired I am so tired of the fake
news media weaponizing the word misogyny
I revoke it I revoke this word you don't
get it anymore all right it is gone if
you're gonna call everything
misogynistic there's no such it doesn't
even exist because you guys use misogyny
for everything and as a woman I am tired
I am tired
if anything if anyone should be talking
about misogyny shouldn't it be me
and you don't even hear me whining
it's just a bunch of freaking whiners
big whiners
oh [__]
the idea that I made primary school
children misogynistic because I own a
nice car is that your argument that
comes along with it oh owning a nice car
is misogynist no it's the misogyny that
comes along with
the suddenly come along with only a nice
car because you you're you have an image
of financial I'm glad you're answering
my questions now we finally got the name
we have an image of Finance you can
answer my questions excuse me you have
an image of financial success but it
comes along with attitude
attitude that are really problematic my
attitudes towards women is that women
should be protected and provided for and
I've said that at length in fact I've
said that over 50 times online you never
mention it I say that my girlfriend
doesn't have to work unless she wants to
I take care of her I die to protect the
woman I've talked about how I've stood
up and faced a knife to protect a woman
you want authority over her in the way
you have over a child or a dog
absolutely not I've said that women
should be protected and provided for and
I in return you want authority over her
because if you have responsibility for
someone like a child or a dog you say
you have authority over them I mean we
are kind of like children as women I
mean let's just
it's like one minute the kid's hungry
one minute the kid's tired one minute
the kid wants candy one minute the kid
wants Pizza like kids they're all over
the place you know I I was just hanging
out with my little cousin this weekend
and you know one minute she's like I
want to live with you and go home with
you forever and then the next minute
she's like I miss my mom and I identify
with that as a woman
I mean there's a lot of similarities I'm
not saying we're the same
but as a woman I can recognize there are
a lot of similarities between the two if
you want to go down this argument we'll
go down this nuanced argument I said
that if I have responsibility for her
safety I should have a degree of
authority over her safety meaning
meaning and let me explain my point if
I'm the one who has to fight and die to
protect her I'm the one who decides how
we walk home I'm the one who decides the
group we take because it's unfair for
her to say I want to walk through the
most dangerous neighborhood in the world
but you have to face the knives that's
what I've said I know you're going to
sit here and pretend I'm trying to treat
women like dogs which is garbage every
single man every single man in the world
who loves this woman understands that he
has to protect her and every single
woman in the world likes the idea of a
woman of a man who would protect her if
you were to say to most women home right
now do you want your husband to protect
you in a violent attack they'd say yeah
of course nothing I've said is the
[__] in those women would you want to
lose Authority in the relationship to
not be treated as a free and legal equal
to your I didn't say that I said I need
to have authority over the route we walk
home when you compare women and the
authority over women that you believe
you should have to having authority over
you can't expect thank you Glenn you
can't expect someone to have
responsibility without Authority that is
true
that is true so you're telling me like
he's gonna protect you he he's gonna pay
all the bills he's going to protect and
provide but he has no authority over
what you do
that sounds horrible I'm just putting
myself in the reverse if I have a kid
right if I have a kid and I'm paying for
the kid
and I'm responsible for the kids safety
I don't have any Authority like telling
it when to go to bed
you know where the kid can and can't go
you that would be kind of unfair right
but we expect men
to do the same I don't know just call me
crazy call me crazy
a child or a dog it's not the same
because a woman is a free legal adult
correct you're equal it's free legal
adult my equal but if I had a girlfriend
and we were walking home late at night
and I said let's not walk down the area
it's a bad area I protect you everything
happens I want to take the long way and
she said no I will I have to walk this
way even though it's the most dangerous
route I must then I would say you're
welcome to you could do it you're a free
legally equal but I'm not going to walk
with you and protect you I think that I
should be able to decide the route
because I have an obligation and my
obligation is a man is to protect and
provide for females everything I'm
talking about is Gen is traditional
gender roles which 10 years ago less
than 10 years ago would not be
considered outlandish would not be
considered crazy would not be considered
dangerous or misogynistic the world has
changed and a lot of people haven't
changed with the world please understand
there's a lot of women at home watching
this right now like the idea of their
man sticking up for them protecting them
protecting them and providing for them
and just because the world has gone
crazy and the Legacy Media has gone
crazy most people at home are still
relatively sane and these are the people
who are going to write on the comment so
Andrew was saying anything that's
outlining
this is invites the whole world believes
these things fine
spiders
yeah that's fine
I'm having a nice conversation I'm
enjoying
so it's no problem it's been fun so far
good
we good
yeah
no no we didn't stop do you think they
knew that Tate was recording also guys
liked the video
there's over there's over a thousand of
you in here we only have five 400 likes
well let's come on come on we should at
least have 600. but do you think do you
think that they knew that Tate was
recording I wonder I don't know I want
to check his Twitter in a second
I can do the clap now we're good thank
you if a man broke into your house and
you want your wouldn't you want your
husband to protect you there's a
difference between conservative values
and emotional control coercive control
we're talking about protection
see this is an example of women only
want Traditional Values when it benefits
them we want all the benefits of
traditionalism okay we want the
protection we want the provisioning we
want to be provided for but
when it comes to giving something up
like we want all the benefits and being
able to give nothing up we want all the
protection and provisioning and all the
freedom to do exactly what we're doing
when we were single
we want all the protection and the
provisioning but we still want to go to
clubs we want all the protection and
provisioning but we want to say about
our trash we want all the protection and
provisioning but we want to be strong
independent women and do whatever we
want
it's not about conservative sorry one
thing men need to realize the difference
between responsibility and fault we
always have the responsibility to act
even if it's not our fault
thank you Glenn
if that is or protection it's what
you're demanding in return for that well
I'll give you this I don't know who your
husband is I don't know if you would
stand up and protect you and die for you
but I'll give you this if someone broke
into this house right now it was a
homicidal maniac I would expect me and
the other men in this room to stand up
and face them while you and you and the
other women in this room could protect
yourselves I would actually believe the
men should go and engage the attacker I
believe that and even though I don't
know you and you've come into my house
with a hostile agenda and you've come
here to try and make me look bad
I would still stand up I would still
stand up and protect you I would still
stand up protect you because I believe
that's my role as a man I am asking you
about things that you have said that
have caused major national organizations
including the police
to worry about you by name that's what
I'm asking you it's not what I say it's
not about what not worrying about him by
name no
why God why
the police are worried they're worried
I miss
we used to be in a world where real
threats counted
now we're in a world where we're worried
about a guy talking on the internet
thank you Amir for the Super Chat guys
we're at 600 likes can we get to 800
that'd be cool there's almost 1 600. I'm
just you know help a girl out you
protect your partner or not it's about
what you have said that has caused such
concern in the UK and I want to put it
to you that you don't really care about
the harm it caused that's not true
because that's not true making
controversial statements like this
online has made you a lot of money okay
so first thing I genuinely am a Force
for good in the world you may not
understand that yet but you will
eventually and I genuinely believe I'm
acting under the instruction of God to
do good things and I want to make the
world a better place I genuinely believe
my legacy is a good Legacy and I believe
that eventually when the Legacy Media
catches up they're going to understand
I'm a good positive influence I'm not
interested in damaging the world for
money
okay this is I will say as a girl some
of this stuff is hard to hear
and I will even admit when I first saw
Tate when I first saw a lot of the red
pill guys as a girl I wasn't a fan but
you listen you listen some more
and you realize everything they're
saying is pure facts it's pure facts
nothing they're saying is untrue it's
just a lot of stuff the world has never
heard before because we live in such a
gynocentric social order that panders to
women so a lot of this stuff is like
crazy to us we've never heard of it but
in the long run it is better for us to
know the way that men think rather than
live in delusion
yes
if I was interested in damaging the
world for money I could have sold drugs
or I could make rap music and encourage
everyone to stab each other like all the
drill artists do you can make
controversial statements online that
attract a lot of followers who you then
direct to your website I could make I
could make jokes I mean I could make I
could make jokes online who doesn't I
mean I could make a joke he says if
taters are concern then so should
destiny
another thing I actually don't like
Destiny's all right I actually don't
have a big issue with Destiny but I
think he's really biased when it comes
to the Tate stuff I think he just has
his narrative he's trying to spin he
knows he gets clout for like talking
about Tate and spinning this narrative
um I don't think he actually believes
that Tate is a human trafficker I don't
think he actually believes that he's
dangerous and I think a lot of the stuff
like that Destiny goes at Tate for it's
like really hypocritical
because we all know
that Destiny stream for years and we
could
take clips and spin it a certain way
this show this shows you that the BBC's
without edit that they just crap yeah
um
and
that that's my thing is a lot of these
reaction channels
the drama channels the TMZ they're
looking to spin a narrative and they
don't go into anything in good faith
like they they they're not looking for
facts
and they'll die on their Hill they'll
die on it and I'll even say at one point
I wasn't even the biggest fan of some of
these guys
but
true is true you know
other controversial things you've said a
joke no I'm saying that these
organizations and the BBC are going to
sit here but then I am the face damaging
the youth is absolutely garbage it's
completely disingenuous and the reason
and the reason
and
I'm talking right now
so these are very limited questions and
this is not what we discussed and this
is not a conversation that we agree we
were very clear that the questions
answers have been provided so if we
could please move on from this side of
the interview yo this is what happened
to me at trigonometry
this is what happened to me at
trigonometry okay I haven't even spoken
about this
I'm not looking to do that as an
interviewer I don't I don't want to get
any gotchas I don't want to like Corner
somebody even even when Brittany Renner
came in and you know she's done a lot of
crazy stuff like I still go into
interviews in good faith and if the
person ends up being lying or whatever
in the interview like people will
correct it later it's fine but
my issue is that again they're going in
with a narrative they're not going into
things in good faith with an open mind
all the questions are biased and pointed
um you should see his most Twitter posts
with of jump Cuts okay I'll look at the
Twitter later yeah trigonometry I went
on this trigonometry podcast and they
freaking
um what do you call it at the end they
just were like hammering me with the
Nick questions and I was just like you
know I don't really want to talk about
this and they just kept going
and not only that they made the worst
trailer ever I was so irritated
I was like that whole interview didn't
didn't leave the
you know best taste in my mouth to be
honest you know I felt like it was kind
of like a trap interview
um I thought because I set it up so much
further back I thought it was just a
general interview about my life
it was not I would appreciate it I would
like to hear what Andrew's got to say
about the fact that when you make
controversial statements it attracts
people to follow you
and then you direct them to your website
where they pay you a monthly fee to
learn how to be like you and so the more
controversial statements you make the
more money you get the fact that that's
the path you've outlined to one my
online university and to my presence on
the internet the fact that you believe
that's the path just shows you've done
absolutely Zeroes
okay people always throw this one at me
too are there are corporate versions of
their corporate versions of Adam preach
yeah
yes they do the same thing they pull
clip clip clip clip clip to spin a
narrative and then the the reaction
channels get so mad when we start
calling this stuff out it's so funny
they get so mad they're like oh you're
out of context as a cope and we're like
no this very clearly was out of context
but anyways anyways back to back to Tate
they don't go into things with an open
mind they're just looking to spin a
narrative TMZ CNN
uh thank you thank you
genuinely zero research okay so how many
of the people who sign up for Hustlers
University come to you through your
social media oh oh sorry I forgot what I
was going to say earlier I get this a
lot that if I say something
controversial and I'm just doing it for
clicks and Views and okay you might say
something in an entertaining way to be
funny
and then people will be like oh you're
just triggering people or you're this
and like no I mean sometimes you say
things in an entertaining way to be
funny I mean that's part of media but to
say you're just trying to trigger people
for no reason
it's like if you just if you just have
controversial opinions
then you're just doing it for me
I hate these reporters genuinely
Services how many of the people who sign
up for Hustler's University
through your social media where you
direct them to the website and Lucy I
encourage you to go out there do some
genuine research watch my videos watch
my videos at length and truly understand
what I'm doing how many of the people
who sign up for Hustlers University at
49.99 a month come to you because they
see your social media comments there's
an online school
called hostels University which I don't
own I influenced four along with many
other influencers and they sign up for
our website which I don't own and once
again that's once again once once once
again there's nothing to do with me and
you're gonna sit here and say that I
made a joke I made a joke online four
years ago because a woman said that she
owned her man's car and you made a joke
and that means that you because you're a
Bugatti are the most misogynistic
dangerous man in the world this is going
down a path of absolute Insanity it's
not true none of this is true I don't
hurt people I don't harm people I'm
genuinely impossible I'm I'm renowned
for offensive unconscious that's not
what I'm renowned I'm actually
but when I interview people on the
street there's tons of people that say
he changed their life got him to start
working out
got them to start making more money get
a better job like I've done these
interviews
so to say he's just everyone doesn't
like him he's just a force for negative
that's not true
action renowned for helping young men
because we talk about those immense
Mental Health crisis we talk about we
pretend to care that men are upset but
as soon as I discuss men's issues it's
misogynistic it doesn't have to be
gender just because I believe men have a
point of view and men have rights and
men are allowed to think and believe and
act a certain way that helps them
internally that doesn't mean it's
anti-female in fact I believe it's
actually pro-female I think when a man
is true to his influence and true to his
s's and he's good within himself he's a
positive influence in the world he's
positive for the women around him just
because I discuss men's issues people
say oh you're anti-woman I'm not
anti-woman I love women why are so many
women saying that when their boyfriends
start following you they're not they
experience more control so many they
experience
how many enough
enough well
ah
not more control it's because modern
women want to do damn near whatever they
want so they'll be like the girls will
be like oh I want to go to the club and
wear damn near nothing and you know the
boyfriends will watch Tate and say you
know maybe we don't do that anymore
let's like that's not okay with me
oh I'm being abused it's like women call
everything abuse
I'm sorry I have
I I I've done shows for too long I've
done them for two
for two I've heard of it so in fact one
is too many oh of course yeah so of in
fact I've seen thousands and thousands
of comments and have endless emails from
women praising the facts praising the
fact that their sons are listening to me
it's praising the fact that the things
I'm saying does not worry it would worry
it would work concerned about it it
would it would worry me if I was
genuinely damaging the world but for you
to sit here and say Andrew you become
the most Googled man in the world you
have billions of views and one woman one
is now saying that her husband is not
the same man she wants him to be when
thousands and thousands of people are
saying the opposite well then I would
say that that's something to do with
case after case after cases quotes after
quotes after quote of people who are
genuinely concerned about the impact
you're having and you brush it off as if
it's nothing no what you have done is
come here with yeah I'm gonna be so
concerned with the feminists are saying
lady there's a lot of crazy people on
the internet
so am I gonna all right if I say fellas
you can leave your fat wives am I gonna
be mad
when the fat wives
get mad at me
no maybe we should say you should give
him a heads up but it's not fair to be
like an obese wife this isn't good but
all the fat chicks get so mad they'll
docks my address
you know do hit piece after hit piece
how do I switch
an agenda you come here with loaded
questions you've come here with things
like map of context you come here with
things that you don't understand it's
satirical and then you're gonna also sit
and say that one woman said that her
boyfriend changed when he watched one of
your videos and and then I don't know
what you expect me to say to that that's
fantastic and jokes no that's how you
explain it for you to sit down I'd like
to apologize for any of that for you to
sit down
for you to sit down
it's fine no it's fine it's easy for you
to sit down and say that one woman said
that her boyfriend watching Andrew take
video and now he won't do the dishes or
whatever your argument is and that I'm
somehow the worst most dangerous man in
the world inside the car it's just
disingenuous and I'm enjoying this
interview very much because this shows
this shows the world it's great it shows
the world the truth about the Legacy
Media because they beg me for interviews
they beg me you have been begging me for
months please we need to be relevant and
then you come here with loaded questions
trying to paint a picture of me which is
completely and utterly false I am a good
positive influence for the world the
things I teach men are stoicism
discipline self-respect hard work
obeying Authority listening to your
fight coach working hard in school
making as much money as possible in your
job if you actually watch the things I
say if you actually watch my comments
about women I've done long podcasts for
hours long about females talking about
protecting for them providing for them
how I believe women should be treated in
a relationship I've done all of this but
you don't watch any of it and then you
come here and ask me to answer questions
I've answered at length thousands of
times since you came out of custody
there seems to have been a lot about
your charity work correct on your social
because all I've always done the charity
work but now I'm promoting it there
seems to be a real shift yeah I wonder
what's behind that well I've always won
the charity work I've been doing the
church
[__]
[__] okay okay
I wonder what's behind your charity work
I wonder like ah
I just I'm so tired of women having the
audacity
I'm just so sick of it we can't just say
good job charity work we we're gonna Mr
Beast him like when Mr Beast made
everyone you know cured from blindness
and people were criticizing him
we're gonna criticize the man for doing
charity work or promoting charity work
but but this is a a good faith interview
you guys like the video there should be
a thousand likes you know come on
I believe that it's my legacy to the
positive influence in the world and I've
been doing charity work for over five
years post
my incarceration my unfair unjust
incarceration man post that I've made it
more clear the charity work I'm doing
but this is again once again very
interesting I spend 25 million dollars a
year feeding children men male children
and female children in in turkey and
Syria and Iran and Iraq I literally
spend 25 million dollars a year feeding
children and I'm still the worst man in
the world because four years ago I made
a sarcastic comment because some people
would look at that and say okay so
before you got money from attracting
people to your website by making
controversial comments but that might
have got you into trouble and so now
you're looking for a new market you're
looking for a new do you like how do you
see how she has new information but she
still doesn't change your opinion he
says no like I tell people to listen to
your fight coach I tell people to make
money I tell people like he's telling
them all the she's he's telling her all
the good things that he does
yet even with the new information
she continues to believe what she
believes
she doesn't backtrack
she doesn't say you know maybe I got you
all wrong
guys like the video let's get a thousand
a thousand likes but she just continues
to keep doing what she's doing and
that's my issue with a lot of these fake
news media channels it's the same thing
on YouTube it's the same thing on bbcc
and misogyny yeah misogyny here we go
thank you Amir
Market of followers who are attracted by
a different sort of persona I've always
done the charity work so that is
obviously incorrect but I have proof
that I've always on the charity works so
you're wrong firstly I believe that if
you have a lot of wealth you should help
people and I'm helping people I honestly
think it's very very interesting that
you cannot find another celebrity in the
UK or anywhere else who's spending 25
million pounds a year feeding children
in war-torn countries I'm doing that
I've been doing that for a long time
without even mentioning it I never even
said it and now that I've said it people
are going to attack me for it and say
that it's disingenuous the person in
Sudan who's eating the meal do you think
they believe it's disingenuous no I
think they I think they feel pretty good
that Andrew takes fed then and to sit
here and say that I'm a bad person now
because I'm manipulating charity because
I'm using cherry I'm just trying to do
good in the world that's all I've ever
been trying to do
when women speak out against you online
disagree with what you say they describe
being bombarded with rape threats and
death threats trolling by your followers
would you like to say anything to your
followers about how to behave and that's
absolutely correct I would love to do
that first things first I've yet to see
a female stand up and argue with me
online I don't ever see hardly any
although women who message me agree with
it secondly I don't think that anybody
who disagrees with me male or female
should be trolled I don't think they
should be insulted or attacked I think
the idea should be discussed openly and
fairly immaturely it doesn't matter if a
man agrees with me or disagree with me
or a female I don't think my followers
should come along and attack her and if
my followers are doing that I'm upset by
that but
let's make a very important
clarification that's not my followers
that's the internet if you were to log
into any video game Lobby I don't play
video games and somewhere to sit there
and say something stupid they would be
trolled with similar comments that's the
unfortunate reality of the internet as a
whole that's nothing to do with me but I
encourage all of my followers to open to
engage in open discourse and be fair and
honest and talk in a way which is mature
there's no need to troll anybody male or
female
okay okay
I wonder if it'd be worth giving Andrew
or no opportunity
consider whether or not he would like to
apologize or
give
you know
the last thing it's not letting me
switch
blessing
awesome
um
oh there we go do we sorry guys we had a
tech issue do we think that
we're he's gonna apologize put a one in
the chat
put a one in the chat if you think he's
going to apologize two in the chat if
you think he's not going to apologize
let's guess one in the chat two in the
chat
yeah I'm I'm on the edge of my seat I
want to I want to see
also guys like the video we're at a
thousand likes I appreciate that
um I'd really like to get to 1.2 1.3
um just so we can make sure the stream
gets pushed out okay
all right let's see one in the chat if
he's gonna apologize no not not even one
shout out to blessing hi Glenn thank you
for the supers uh a three not one one in
the chat guys he seems really remorseful
Maybe
maybe oh I see a one two three not a lot
wow
top G does top G apologize let's see
Keisha
influence young people UK the second
thing I think we should go and records
that this interview is taking place in
your house because you're under house
arrest if it were not for that then we
would have chosen another location I'm
sure we would have negotiated that
between us
wow she's pulling an album preach hey we
just came to your home because we had to
there was no loyalty here don't expect
any loyalty okay we are here because we
had to be here she's pulling in Abba
look it I I didn't know your podcast was
at your house
all right guys what what are we thinking
still in the chat what is there to
apologize for
oh he is
um all right is there any ones any ones
in the chat on the edge of his seat guys
what come on get to 1.2 likes in here I
really want to get to 1.5 before the
edge of the end of the stream I saw
someone else got 1.5 I was like it's a
good goal all right
let's see so I think that's just worth
it okay
um
so just to put on the record then you've
said that you've invited us into your
house correct we're here because you're
under house arrest correct if you were
free to leave we would have negotiated a
more neutral setting don't you think as
the BBC it'd be very interesting to come
here and discuss the fact that I was put
in a dungeon for 92 days and then locked
enhanced arrest without charge so you
think that's a far more interesting
conversation than old YouTube Snickers
do you think that would be interesting
you're interesting put one in the chat
one in the chat
I I would just you know guys I know
sometimes
I don't come prepared to everything all
right I'm human right I I do so much
content that sometimes you can't be
prepared for everything
but if I'm going to interview
the most the most Wanted interview on
the planet you don't think I mean I
would have questions on both sides you
know
does he apologize maybe he's gonna
apologize I don't know I don't know
guys all right 1.1
switch because it's an ongoing
investigation into rape and human
trafficking allegations against correct
I've been incarcerated without charge
and don't you think
has been dropped
correct so I am I'm incarcerated without
charge and I think that'd be a far more
interesting conversation than I guess
Julian Assange is incarcerated without
charge and nobody's interested in that
either so if you actually want to do
some genuine journalism investigation we
could talk about the fact that an
innocent man who was yet been charged
with a crime has had his Liberty
deprived of him and I think that would
be a far more interesting angle than
talking about me being the most
dangerous man in the world's eye on the
car
BBC
and this question about schools being
very worried about your influence not
the schools no
gosh the schools are worried they're
worried you know guys I'm gonna tell you
a story okay one time when I was in high
school the schools were worried because
my mom took me to Florida for two weeks
my own mother
and they tried to expel me over it
schools are worried about the craziest
things the schools are like liberal
institutions
um
damn it Pearl didn't Kevin Samuels teach
you anything you want them to get the
likes up pause the show and play some
annoying music until the likes are up
I should do that
you know I'm a real journalist out here
I'm just saying
he's in primary school or you know boys
as young as 11 are quoting you at school
attacking girls
refusing to respect female teachers what
should we call BBC let's let's make up a
name for them I like this idea from the
chat
um the
bimbo broadcast
bimbo
the what could BBC stand for
what could what could BBC stand for
what are you something wrong
turn the volume down this one
look for it this way
okay
the British
British bullcrap bullcrap
BBC the woke bimbo broadcast Corporation
I like these
big bull crap big bull crap BBC big bull
crap
barely basic communication
blue ball Chads
uh the British Broadcasting cap
the bimbo broadcasting coronation
um thank you queen bird for the two
dollar super
Big Brand crap
British bias the British bias
Corporation
the bloody bimbo cast
let me know in the comments guys because
we're almost at the end of the stream
let me know what you think we should
call the BBC
um
oh he's gonna call soon okay
um Pearl reader comments give me I'm
gonna be done streaming tell tell sneak
while be done streaming in five all
right would you like to say anything
about that I like to say law first
things first as I've repeatedly said and
the only reason I keep repeating is
because I'm sure this interview will be
edited I am a positive force of the
world I teach children discipline I
teach the world discipline male or
female of any age and a lot of women
listen to me as well 40 of the people
listen to me are actually female
secondly I do understand with my 40 I'm
surprised it's that high massive
influence and I am now the one most
influential people on the planet that I
do have to be slightly more careful with
things I say I'm not going to disagree
with that the idea that I said something
five years ago on a video that got 300
views so what do you mean being slightly
more careful I'll give you an example
some of the jokes I made four or five
years ago on a YouTube channel they got
300 views I would no longer make like
the only famous joke the one you
mentioned repeat when she said my man's
car is my car and then she said she did
only fans and I said what you saw on
only fans said my tits and I said well
those are your man's tits as a joke
hahaha everybody laughed the point the
fact that I could do that on a podcast
five years ago and only got 300 views
yeah you guys are pulling up some stuff
I did
it's like that that at the time kind of
funny you guys do that you do that yeah
you do speak differently when you're at
300 views versus 300 million you know
now I understand I'm the most
influential man on the face of the
planet I would be more careful with
certain things I say that doesn't mean
the things I originally said were
genuinely out to harm people do you
really believe you're the most
influential man on the face of the
planet I know it's Google person on the
planet do you believe you're the most
influential man on the face of the
planet and there was Googled man on the
planet
I think we're done yeah she thinks we're
done
Buster Bert's Channel
he is he like let's just call it call it
what it is guys
he
yeah yeah okay
okay thanks Lucy
is enjoyable nice to meet you
no it was fun it was good
I enjoyed it
dmic me I don't want to damage anything
thank you
very nice to meet you thank you thank
you thank you goodbye
status
finally you get to see Andrew side go
he's coming you forwards in the comment
section please
I've I've had that moment after an
interview that's how it was on um
what's it called the the trigonometry I
was quite pissed I could definitely tell
I was pissed because I didn't think they
were going to Corner me with the Fuentes
stuff
I've had those awkward ah thank you so
much
you know
but guys on your way out okay like the
video I I really would like to get to
1.5 likes I think that's a fair ask
right for this this beautiful stream
that we've done
um and let me know in the comments okay
do you do you think Tate is guilty of
anything is there any crap do you think
he's gonna get charged with a crime
eventually or do you think they're gonna
let him go I think at this point if they
were going to charge them they would
have I think they're trying to find
something in the last month but
it's my opinion is that they've been
searching into him for a year if he was
really that dangerous they would have
found something
um also let me know what in the comments
we should Name BBC what should we I want
to get some acronyms going for some of
these fake news media channels so let me
know in the comments uh what we should
call BBC and some other fake news
channels on the internet I'm not going
to say names but let me know in the
comments
um and maybe should should Tate
Apologize One in the chat two I'm just
kidding okay like the video on your way
out guys subscribe to the what
okay press off okay like the video on
your way out guys please get us to 1.5
likes I'd really like to hit that